[Musica]
ora tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo su
de fontaine ragazzi the bold and sarebbe
sarebbe questo kit che tanto che dall
altra un figo e non ragazzi gioco tanto
per farvi capire che noi ci capiamo
favo ragazzi chiunque viene consigliato
questo gioco per tipo una settimana
mette bombardato di richieste dicendo
fari e gioca the fall denny che è un
videogioco simile hackett mario quindi
immaginate che gioia nel giocare sta
roba concreto non avete chiesto in
tantissimi chissenefrega
proviamoci lo stesso alla guida c'è un
party c'è un party non avete invitato me
ma siete pazzi
vai col scrive poi il suo stile di ballo
c'è tutta la discute aspetti cazzo è
stati sia ha detto ma [ __ ] mi ha
rubato l'amico stralciare è quello
continua a ballare come un deficiente ma
se vuoi te ne sei accorta adesso bravo
bravo o sei strafatto di canne o sei
stupido una di una delle due perché è
passato un elicottero grosso come il
duomo ci siamo ragazzi la scelta dei
livelli con catherine questa mai una
devo quindi credo che si possa finire
entro oggi che c'è perché comunque
essendo una demo dovrebbe essere
abbastanza allunga new york sexy auto
jump questo lo sapevo e poi dobbiamo
anche a lui che cazzo è successo se mi è
caduto in testa ho visto cioè da coinsar
ben dire che non posso prenderlo in mano
io esplodo se prendo lemon fantasmi
comunque dobbiamo arrivare bar ma ti sei
fumato veramente ma tante canners long
way down news and platform domanda rendo
mandare sulla fiat non devo andare sulle
piattaforme allora siamo arrivati al
check point grazie a dio amon onna
madonna [ __ ] da quando le spine
sono diventate molli o gioco
ricapitolando ti ammazzano le monete
porca [ __ ] z time grande idea diranno
che è perfetto ma guarda che sono
proprio [ __ ] nel cervello ma porca
[ __ ]
si ok profilo prendo il trofeo lo prendo
no non lo prendo il trofeo perché salta
in aria anche con quello ma si può per
far fare una ragazzina veramente si può
fare non avevate anche detto ma è simile
a chies mariano cascone pregio e salto
ok bene mi sono fatto sedurre dalla sua
bellezza mi veniva voglia di mangiarla
allora non mi sono tolto però
evidentemente mi fanno male anche i
muffin ragazzi non ho toccato nulla
quindi va bene
[Musica]
ho vinto ho visto prima che mi
raggiungesse baffino vinto è stata non
mi chiedete come ho fatto non ne ho la
piu pallida
[Musica]
tutto il contrario degli altri giochi
che in poche parole le monete
t'ammazzano le spine invece fanno bene
[ __ ] used dieta running start che
la festa cosa non da a sinistra si no si
sta incamminando il cervello raga io ve
lo dico io stesso l'ho preso no no
ragazzi come faccio a passare di qua
impossibile e come cibo ma quando possa
uccidere se si alto sopra uncino che
cazzo l'impiegata ragazzi sta cosa sta
cosa raffinata
abbiate pazienza all you need is love
non volevo neanche toccarlo ma ci sono
finito sopra lo stesso va beh ok ok mio
dio
chapeau non ci posso credere cosa dare
sulla nuvola per non prendere le spirali
noi non devo saltare a la nuvola mi
ammazza ha già giusto che le spine mi
fanno saltare porca [ __ ] meno
dimenticato e non prendono anche il
trofeo perché mi ammazzano la vado
avanti di qua ok ok questo che cosa
cazzo dovrebbe essere lo prendo
[Musica]
non lo sapevo lo sapevo non ci posso
passare attraverso come [ __ ] il
mio culo a fuoco grande così mio dio
ragazzi è stato è stato l'accordo non so
neanche come ho fatto rai to keep your
lives at hasc hisc time va bene
[ __ ] ai muffin le molle perfetto
come queste mi manca non mi ammazzo
numero 1 alle molle non ti parlo salta
un fantastico fatto di qua non ho male
allora fermi fermi che è complicata la
situazione devono passare di qua
perfetto è ma come cazzo faccio c'è un
trofeo di troppe ma non lo è ho giocato
per sbaglio ma li posso far fuori ma
fiper grandissimo porca [ __ ] ci avrei
messo anni per scoprirlo allora devo
andare ferla non me lo ricorderò
fottutamente maiale monete non me la
devo prendere maledizione come faccio
qui e dico ci sono andato no no si no
non ci sono andato cos'è sta roba
ragazzi a di carangelo passato perfetto
è né così devo io non ci vada del tanto
che cazzo di dollari quando perfetto
perfetto
perfetto il suo affetto sto cazzo la
posso fare la gara nei prossim possibile
dove i quali i conigli stanno sul culo
devo riuscire a passarli grande cos'è a
prefetto quel traguardo di qua devo
saltare perfetta questa ma ricordavo
ma che cazzo fa il cambio perché
falchetti a style o panca nam st
ragazzi è il mio photocall il
personaggio di videogioco balling andiam
stai una volta che finisce un livello
non l'ho mai visto lo gioco è un
qualcosa di troppo strano dunque
lo slow you may make it no non vado
piano perché sono caso lo so già non
vuole importante ragazze che riesco a
capire
c'era c'era c'erano due cazzo di monete
nello spazio di un chilometro porca
[ __ ] che cosa ho preso io
maledizione non è possible kate ok ok
[ __ ] due tra sorella ma possiamo fare
possiamo fare si si salta la moneta si
grande non ci posso credere che posso
fare in forza di vento più bravo clan a
[ __ ] i muffin
oddio oddio ragazzo solo un fenomeno
sono un fenomeno deve evitare la
nuvoletta ok definivano ancora ok allora
sì sì sì grande ma dio mio che fenomeno
ai vai si grande grazie così dio mio che
valgo il genio stai troppo forte legame
manca in due
cazzo già possiamo fare raga non ci
posso credere la prima volta che finisco
il gioco alla prima primo tentativo non
è così semplice passare sotto le monete
la tua sorella passa sotto le molecole
che captain ma ci sono i muffin di merda
non è colpa mia
ok ok se c'è malizia al dopo e non lo
prendono la mira su kakà su un camp nou
fra solo un [ __ ] andavano di la
prima perché sono arrivati di quattro
fermi carmi farmi mangiami veloce
scusami poi grange chiusi il che bello è
quando viene sparato dalle piante
ragazzi guardate che figo come normale
quindi quello sì
ok lo stata pressa jump out sider
l'avevo capito neanche neanche i
consigli sono così possono leggere
protetti fottono fantastico ma si deve
incazzare quando gioca sta roba ma voi
capite non è così semplice non
incazzarsi in giochi del genere perciò
posso fare saltare simone tesi ok grazie
non so neanche io come ho fatto saltare
così ma va bene così io guardavo li
guarda lo diritto come cazzo fa
non ci posso credere già non siamo
all'ultimo livello
una corsa su tarda ad arrivare al
livello 6 il postino tu sei il tizio che
ballava come all'inizio e scusami se non
ti ho visto ma ero sta affatto di canne
devo cosa devo fare
devo essere portato via quindi non
sarebbe più un cazzo alla fine dove vai
dove cazzo fai ma no per adesso quel
povero stronzo chi sa il vero io donna
il quadro ghazi io io non c'ho no no ma
guardare impossibile allora devi finire
qui tu l'ho fatto perché hanno fatto
no no no no no no no ok no e troy aveva
allora non peccare la nuvoletta e non
avevo capito e lo stato
la posso fare sorpreso ma come ho fatto
io no mi ai cuori nei cuori [ __ ]
allora non voglio il tuo amore
luca zocco ragazzini giu sto sudando
freddo impossibile falck a roma ok se ti
sta bene
[ __ ] 20 amica mia come faccia
raggiungere da usare la nuvola vinicola
di goku mutande ragazzi ciao ciao dovrei
aver fatta che no perché ho battuto
contro un cazzo di cose a noi invece ce
lo fa grande ok ce la posso non ci posso
credere è stata un'avventura di quelle
che supermario prossimi fa una pippa e
possiamo tornare a ballare skrillex in
pace anche poi i ragazzi io vorrei farvi
notare il ballo di dei bimbi entrambi
perché sono uno più demente dell'altro è
stato assurdo come videogioco che vi
ringrazio per averlo consigliato perché
mi ha fatto stare abbastanza quindi vi
voglio bene
fatemi sapere se volete che io lo faccia
quando uscirà perché mi piace come cosa
è abbastanza carina come al solito seguì
dove è piaciuto al commento mi piace
anche alla faccia di facebook che come
non i video plate nella descrizione a
sera senato rischi discrete vino ci
rivediamo in questione
bella ragazza